Namor the Sub-Mariner is a pretty cool comic
book character.
The first real anti-hero in comics, he's fought alongside Captain America, has a wealth
of exotic powers, and rocks a form-fitting
speedo.
Diehard fans have clamored for a Namor movie
for years.
And with complex rights issues surrounding
the character reportedly resolved, it would
seem like the time is finally right.
But so far there's been no sign of Marvel's
oldest superhero.
Here's a look at why Marvel won't give Namor
a movie.
Too many worlds
The Marvel Cinematic Universe has explored
other dimensions, distant worlds, and even
the realms of the gods.
Yet in all of those travels, and through all
the world-threatening catastrophes we've seen
on screen, the only sign of Namor's underwater
kingdom of Atlantis was a brief Easter egg
on a map.
And that might be for good reason.
Once Marvel introduces a race of superhuman
merfolk led by a benevolent monarch, fans
are going to start wondering just why they
aren't, you know... doing anything.
Think about your buddy who always asks "why
don't the Avengers just show up" every time
you see a solo Marvel movie.
With Namor in the picture, everyone's going
to ask why his army of fish people don't swim
in and save the day.
And seriously: it'll stop being funny after
the second time.
Impossible backstory
Namor has a really cool origin — and it
pretty much doesn't make any sense in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe.
The Prince of Atlantis has supposedly been
around since World War II, fighting alongside
Cap and the Invaders.
But we know from Captain America: The First
Avenger that no fish folk were anywhere to
be seen.
And explaining why Namor hasn't even shown
up at any point in the last 75 years of MCU
continuity would be even trickier than Marvel's
efforts to thread the Winter Soldier into
historical events.
With SHIELD and Hydra both aggressively tracking
superhuman threats, you'd think someone would
have noticed Namor and Atlantis at some point.
Explaining why they haven't appeared on anyone's
radar to this point makes Namor's story that
much more difficult to tell.
Worst Kryptonite ever
In many ways, our superheroes are measured
by their weaknesses, like the all-powerful
Superman being taken out by Kryptonite.
Or imps from the fifth-dimension!
But while Kryptonite and wacky imps are in
relatively short supply, Namor has a much
more common weakness: air.
Yes, that's right.
You see, Namor gets his powers from water,
so the longer he's out of water, the weaker
and weaker he gets.
"The sea!
I must reach the sea!"
If that's not enough, he's also weakened when
he comes in contact with polluted water, which
means he's pretty much doomed in today's world.
When your hero needs to wear a Camelbak in
order to keep from dying, chances are he's
going to have a really short career.
Similarity to Aquaman
Speaking of aquatic superheroes who gain their
powers from water, one of the primary reasons
we'll never see a Namor movie is that DC is
beating Marvel to the punch by releasing a
movie about Aquaman first.
"Arthur Curry.
I hear you can talk to fish?"
They're essentially the same character — superstrong
kings of Atlantis who can communicate with
marine life — the only differences being
that Aquaman is a nerd and Namor is a stud.
It's ironic that, even though Aquaman is much
better known, he's actually a total ripoff
of Namor, who first appeared in comics pages
two years earlier.
Still, that's not going to matter much to
film audiences.
To them, Namor's going to seem like the copycatfish,
and that's a big blow to his film future.
The mutant problem
While Marvel Chief Creative Officer Joe Quesada
stated in the summer of 2016 that Marvel has
regained the film rights to Namor, it's still
complicated by other rights issues.
You might have heard that stories set in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe can't mention mutants
— because the rights to mutants live at
20th Century Fox with the X-Men.
That's why the Avengers version of Quicksilver
was a "miracle" created by HYDRA.
And this is a problem for Namor, because Marvel
Comics has long marketed him as "the world's
first mutant," explaining his super-strength
and flight as genetic mutations.
Combined with the other issues surrounding
his backstory, it seems like any version of
Namor we might see on screen would essentially
have to be an entirely different character.
The terrorism thing
Remember when we called Namor an anti-hero?
Well, he also sometimes just veers straight
into the realm of flat-out villainy.
In many of his earliest stories, he vented
his rage on arrogant surface dwellers by randomly
trashing their cities.
Later, when he thought Atlantis had been destroyed
by nuclear testing, he vowed to destroy all
of humanity, attempting to level New York
using a giant walking whale monster even after
he learned his people were actually totally
fine.
One time he even destroyed Black Panther's
home country of Wakanda, just for funsies.
Namor's moral ambiguity is hardwired into
the character's appeal, but superhero cinema
and Marvel movies in particular don't leave
much room for this kind of nuance.
Without it, though, Namor is just another
guy, albeit a guy in a scaly thong.
Which is fine for Magic Mike 3, but maybe
not so great for Avengers 3.
He makes for a better foil
Historically, Namor has been a great character
for others to play off of, but not all that
interesting on his own.
He's a cool rival for the affections of the
Invisible Woman, an intriguing ally for the
X-Men, a complex villain for the Avengers,
and a great foil for the original Human Torch.
But his solo adventures have been kind of
lackluster, with his last comic book series
running just 11 issues before it was cancelled.
It's possible Marvel could find a way to use
Namor as a member of a team like the Avengers,
or as a villain for one of their TV shows
or something.
But as the lead in a solo feature film?
If history is our guide, that seems unlikely.
The MCU that could have been
Regardless of the impossibility of his own
movie, it's fun to imagine what Namor might
have brought to the Marvel Cinematic Universe.
It would be cool to see Namor shouting "Imperius
Rex!" while repelling the next round of alien
invaders, or punching Thanos in his stupid
purple face.
Alas, the Namor movie is less likely to happen
than a gritty cinematic reboot of Howard the
Duck.
In the finest Marvel Comics tradition, his
fans are simply left to imagine "what if?"
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!